peut-être un mot pour commencer la mort
de raymond poulidor qu'on a appris ce
matin il est âgé de 83 ans mais il était
resté jusqu'au bout passionné par le
cyclisme
écoutez ce commentaire qui faisait de
son dernier tour de france c'était en
juillet dernier c'est au tour de france
comme les autres
un tour de france on se souviendra un
tour de france très disputé
très dur un des plus durs des tours de
france disputé le meilleur tour de
l'histoire
je pencherais renée fregosi les français
ont beaucoup d'affection pour raymond
poulidor on le voit avec le les hommages
qui se multiplient depuis ce matin
pourtant ce n'était pas notre plus grand
champion
comment expliquez-vous cet engouement ce
lien très particulier qui avait entre
lui et les français a ajouté moi je suis
pas du tout spécialiste de cyclisme et
je déteste le vélo mais je dois dire que
pelé d'or et lass c'est toute mon
enfance donc anquetil poulidor je
connaissais alors que je détestais le
tour de france et surtout les le rythme
des commentaires
c'est insupportable pour moi mais
effectivement poulidor et après donc
j'ai appris qu'il a continué à
s'intéresser beaucoup et cyclisme et il
était très populaire mais parce que oui
c'était c'était une figure alors pour
certains depuis l'enfance et puis
ensuite après tout moi je ne peux pas
l'expliquer
sociologiquement autrement que ça en
tous les cas moi c'est sans doute de la
nostalgie voilà alors polydor on le sait
était arrivé de nombreuses fois numéro 2
de course c'est christ qu'elle y
participer d'où cette question que je me
pose peut-être un peu bêtement est ce
que les français aiment les numéros deux
questions ouvertes qui ne l'est pas
qu'il veut répondre de panache de
laisser la place au numéro un et donc en
france on aime bien on aime bien ces on
aime bien imaginer que c'est par
politesse qu'il a laissé la place durant
ces mois j'étais un peu si ramon un peu
beauté du geste voilà et c'est cette
espèce de d'attitude qu'il a toujours
d'être souriant et c'est un être qu'on a
envie d'aimer poulidor c'est quelqu'un
qui représente comme vous disiez une
certaine france qu'on aime bien
un commentaire sur raymond pollueurs
entre anquetil qu'on aurait pu qualifier
de premier de cordée et poulidor c'était
de monde
il ya peut-être cette manière de se
rapprocher d'un monde voilà peut-être
plus besogneux qui n'y arrive pas mais
qui donne de l'espoir
donc il ya à l'inversé de rené c'est pas
du tout ma jeunesse mais du coup moi ce
que je retiens est ce qui a traversé du
coup les générations c'est ça c'est ce
personnage qui se battaient pour essayer
justement d'arriver là où il n'avait pas
pu réussir à régler ce cas il a une très
belle carrière avec beaucoup de
victoires on retient juste qu'il n'a pas
gagné le tour de france et qui n'a pas
porté maillot jaune enfin gardez vous
n'êtes pas obligé d'avoir un point de
vue sur ce sujet interrogé ce matin
aussi sur une radio concurrente et j'ai
été forcé d'admettre que c'était pas
avant de ma génération
et comme je m'intéresse à beaucoup
cyclisme je ne sais pas beaucoup sur ce
monsieur si moi je rends hommage à
l'activité je pratique beaucoup le vélo
donc être pour moi qu'ils méritent
[Rires]